Well, to get the first term in both of our answers, we just squared the first
term, x times x is x squared, and 3x times 3x is 9x squared. So again we're
going to start off with a, a squared. We square the first term. This middle term
is just like from before except instead of being positive they're negative. So I
take the first term, multiply it by the second term, and then multiply it by 2.
X times negative 4 is negative 4x times 2 is negative 8x. 3x times negative 1 is
negative 3x times 2 is negative 6x. So, we take the first term,a, multiply it by
the second term, negative b, and then multiply it by 2, and we get negative 2ab.
This last part is simply this last term squared. Negative 4 times negative 4 is
positive 16. Negative 1 times negative 1 is positive 1. So we know negative b
times negative b is positive b squared. There's our pattern.